so if if he's pushing on me right and I
send his energy down to the ground he's
pushing on me
right all right same thing if I punch
him but not here that energy comes back
down to the
ground all right we're on the kick now
okay so we're we're going to do our KCK
here and my drill is contact and then
continue
that that mass is resistance it will
come down this way and I'll project it
out so I'm not kicking it going through
the Dynamics and then the ground
Vector okay so he's not picking up his
leg for me that's not what he's doing
I'm able to just move his leg from
here okay that is enough base to
generate that energy let's
go
you're just using your quadrip
right just ground Vector don't push your
hand this this
energy all right you're pushing on me
push on me goes into that
that you're pushing
right push knock me
over that push in that
way and your that energy go in that leg
goes
down
you're change you're hooking him you
see just open your just open your leg
like the
kick all you're going to do is open your
leg
just don't hook them just just open your
whoa so here here
you're going
your sometimes you're going like
this I'll give you a little energy
okay not going like
this okay so I'm not touching him all
right I'm not going like
this just here that that the same thing
what I was trying to show he's pushing
you know these drills he's pushing he's
pushing he's pushing right you know
those drills okay you're just doing it
ballistically and from not that position
this is still energy I'm grounding
it trying to move that is energy I
ground it so I I take that resistance
put it in that foot and let it
LO okay
go
okay so you feel it's bouncing you off
right okay so keep going
way ground that energy in your foot
you're just trying to move it
ballistically ground that first feel it
into your foot
okay A little
better put this in your
foot a little better try to do it with
the kick though get rid of that
hook and see you bounced off of it
okay uh so as as I'm coming around uh
the last comment I made there's no you
see all this get ready go and then go I
don't I'm not doing that okay um so I'm
going to touch touch that
okay and then this this is all
new you feel that
okay so without the movement I'm already
in just like just like I'm touching here
I'm already inion see okay here I am
there it is you're in see so no movement
she she she'll feel it you guys don't
feel she's right on the edge you see and
then all I do is open
my okay all right no no winding up and
all that kind of stuff okay all right
okay so you you can uh if I was going to
punch uh you can punch with shoulder oh
you punch with shoulder and hip rotation
that that punch feels different from
that punch you see it's not the same
punch so likewise we're doing this low
round you can hit this back pretty
pretty athletic that's not the same kick
it's not the same kick okay so I'm going
to have that resistance come into the
base totally displace his
body some things you'll notice is the
back heel is down usually
athletic this is all hip rotation
they're not grounded okay but I have to
ground on the back
leg okay let's
go see that you're kind of bouncing off
the
[Music]
target don't don't put your hands where
boxes with your hands we don't have
gloves
get them off your
face got to turn the bottom foot don't
kick across your
body a lot of momentum not much
projection okay try the other side
again you're going to feel the
resistance of the bag that goes to the
ground
this pretty soft right right it's pretty
soft through the bag on the
ground come on good more
displacement
good
good round the back foot boom good
that's
it
good
good nose forward nose
forward no eyes forward forward forwards
right now forward
12:00 you come coming back against the
kick
again
see your upper body comes back okay
energy goes against the kick is taking
energy from the kick you'll feel strong
but you won't be
strong okay so energy goes across again
it's not how powerful I feel this makes
me feel a lot of torqueing here and it
makes me feel powerful but my Mass is
going out of the force equation it's not
actually powerful okay so uh everything
has to be going in the
direction that the kick is going except
for my nose because my nose is facing
the opponent my eyes are facing the
opponent okay but to just show you how
easy that
is not not trying to fight anyone just
trying to have all my energy you
go into this motion
not okay even a tiny
one that that little one that's going to
take energy out of the K so everything
is
relaxed and goes in the same direction
so we're going to do this drill it's
basically a kid
drill okay that's all you're
doing
okay try
it good it's all in the back foot ground
the back foot that's
it good very
nice there you
go there you go find the back foot
there you
go there you go find the back foot that
is what we're drawing the back foot
good just swing
good do the other side again Lower the
bag good back
foot feel the blood in your fingertips
there you
go good much
better then you get don't put your hands
where boxers put their hands don't if
you put your hands on your face it's
going to be like cro uh what was that
game croquet cro okay you know that game
their fist is going to hit your fist
your fist is going to hit your head
okay swing feel the energy feel that
same s trifocal
energy good that's
it good back foot same thing back foot
swing
good let's do the other side other
side feel it imagine your fingertips are
still out there
okay there you go good good on the back
foot very
nice whoops heel came up okay bend the
back
knee bend the back knee bend it much
better came up a little okay you got to
trust it
again oops try it again leave that heel
down back heel your left heel
[Music]
much better